[Musique]
la chose la plus importante en ce moment
est que tu dises la vérité
[Musique]
notre rapport a été déposé nous connaissons
toute l'histoire
je voulais me sentir libre je voulais faire
ce que je voulais pour la première fois de ma
vie
[Musique]
c'est ton élève c'est comme un
abus de pouvoir monumental
tout le monde panique à propos de cet homme
la police est venue chez moi aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec toi eric
a miss wilson a déjà été
inapproprié avec toi je t'aime je t'aime
ils ont émis un  mandat d'arrêt
je ne peux pas manger
je ne peux pas dormir je ne peux pas avancer dans
ma vie
[Musique]
je dois vivre avec ça pour toujours alors fais
toi